And once again, we can answer this using a truth table.
Now the truth table will have 36 different entries,
six for the first throw times six for the second throw,
and there isn't enough space on this tablet to draw all the 36 entries.
So, let me just draw the ones that really matter, one-one, two-two, and so on all the way to a six-six.
So, each one of those is a probability of 1/6 for the first outcome times 1/6 for the second,
which gives me 1/36, and the same logic applies everywhere.
So, for all of these six outcomes, I have 1/36 of a chance this outcome would materialize.
Adding them all up gives me 1/6, why?
Because, I get 6 times 36 and I can simply this back to 1/6 that's just the same as 0.16667.
So, 1/6 times, you will get a double
Now, when you're play a game like backgammon, which is played with two dice,
it might not feel like this, I can swear I don't get a double of 1/6 moves,
but it's actually true that that's the right--that's the correct probability.